Speaker 1: So I don't really even know what
to make of this, but radical, deranged, delusional
fantasy world religious televangelist Pat
Robertson, of course, known from the 700 Club,
which has been around for decades at this
point, he did a mostly accurate and pretty
sober and precise assessment of police killings,
including specifically of the killing in Minnesota
of DONTAE.
Right.
It's almost I'm kind of joking here.
It's almost like Pat Robertson became WOAK,
and I'm joking because I don't actually use
that term.
But check out this video.
Pat Robertson's co-host pointing out the entire
Taser versus gun confusion that's being claimed
is a terrible explanation for the officer
involved in the shooting.
Tasers and guns are kept on opposite sides
of police.
Utility belts, guns and tasers feel totally
different.
And then Pat Robertson, I venture to say here,
delivers an impassioned statement about the
issue facing our country.
Check this out.
Talking about George Floyd and Derek Shoven,
the Dante Wright shooting police and more.
I don't know.
It's Pat Robertson.
Take a look
Speaker 4: what else I'm going to say.
You know, I think a lot of people are thinking
like I was, that both gun belts, a gun and
the Taser would be put on your dominant side.
But it's not that would have to have to cross
the hill.
So you actually have to reach across yourself.
So, yeah, it's definitely just as I say, they're
not making Tasers in the shillitoe, really
more than regular in blacks.
They're making them yellow.
Not how she made the difference when she shot
that poor guy to death, saying this is what
this is.
I think it was my taser.
And if you can't tell the difference in the
feel a little is crazy and she deserves.
But, you know, I am told police folks, I think
we need the police, we need their service
and they do a good job.
But if they don't stop this onslaught, they
cannot do this.
You know, the police and Virginia picked up
a lieutenant in the army.
And again, they give him trouble.
And our our our state police are highly trained
for why they stop this and this thing that's
going on in Minnesota.
But the Derek Show, I mean, they all put him
under the jail.
He has caused so much trouble.
But nailing on the deaths of George Floyd
is just I last night.
It's just terrible what's happening.
And the police, why don't they open their
eyes to what the public relations are?
They've got to stop this stuff.
Speaker 1: So there is Pat Robertson at the
age of 91 years coming across a good take.
Somehow it happened.
Now, you know, OK, some of what Pat Robertson
is saying seems to be that lots of this stuff
just makes police look bad versus it's actually
bad that I understand that maybe there's an
aspect of that here.
I've never seen anything like this from Pat
Robertson.
Now, this doesn't make Pat Robertson a progressive
beacon of hope, hope.
But but as he pointed out, even Pat Robertson
seems to realize that the situation in the
country has become completely absurd.
There is an opposite interpretation as well.
If Pat Robertson is actually able to see this
situation for what it is, doesn't it make
it more likely that he realized all of realizes,
all of the other stuff he's saying is bogus,
but he says it anyway in order to get donations
or clicks or ratings or to placate his right
wing religious audience?
I don't know.
The other thing is there are some instances
in Pat Robertson's past where he'll say something
kind of logical and then there will be blowback
and then he'll just backtrack a week later.
I think this happened once with with cannabis
legalization, where he said something that
was pretty, pretty logical.
His audience went nuts.
And next thing we knew, he had basically recanted
his view.
But I do think that the one may be consistent
takeaway is that there are lots of people
who, when they're able to separate themselves
from their partizanship and their tribalism,
they realize at a deep gut level what's going
on with guns and or with police shootings
is not OK.
They get it.
Then very often after they have the gut reaction,
they turn on Fox News or whatever and they
realize, oh, there's partizan talking points
I have to get in line with.
But there's like this brief moment of clarity
that they seem to have.
Then the NRA comes in and they say, no, no,
no, this is evidence.
We need more guns, police should have more
guns and people should have more guns and
they should be easier to buy.
And then they mostly fall in line.
But many of these people, I think for a moment,
get it anyway.
No need to now start praising Pat Robertson
more than he deserves.
But it's an interesting segment, certainly.
Not something I was expecting to see, and
maybe there's like some glimmer of hope here
that there's maybe an opportunity to get consensus
on the issue of guns and police if we can
separate people from their reflexive partizan
reactions.
And that's not easy.
There's a reason that if you go back to the
Sandy Hook shooting, which was what was that,
2012, it's insane that it's been almost a
decade.
If so, you go back to the Sandy Hook shooting
and you had an 88 to 90 percent approval rating
from the country saying we need 100 percent
universal background checks.
It didn't happen even with that level of agreement.
It didn't happen.
And we have almost nothing in this country
where you have 88 to 90 percent agreement.
But people had the gut reaction.
Wait a second.
There are some gun transactions where you
don't need a background check.
That doesn't make sense at a fundamental level.
Then in came the NRA.
In came the Republican politicians and nothing
got done.
So maybe the takeaway here is not Pat Robertson,
beacon of WOAK or beacon of hope or whatever,
but that there's an opportunity there, brief
as it may be, where there may be more agreement
on these issues than it sometimes seems.